vertrag nahezu perfekt eu sichert sich
bei bayern tag und weiser 300 millionen
impfstoffdosen gegen korona
intensivstationen am limit corona kranke
aus frankreich werden in deutschen
kliniken verlegt und kampf gegen
islamistische gewalt deutschland sucht
gemeinsame strategie mit frankreich und
österreich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den spanische wundern dürfen
seit die beiden pharmaunternehmen
biontech und kaiser gestern überraschend
positive testergebnisse für ihren corona
impfstoff verkündeten ist die hoffnung
groß aber auch der druck ist groß sich
möglichst schnell möglichst viel von
diesem vielleicht ersten impfstoff gegen
das virus zu sichern
die eu-kommission steht kurz davor einen
liefervertrag mit biontech und weise zu
unterzeichnen
danach stehen der eu 200 millionen
impfdosen zu für weitere 100 millionen
gibt es eine option
das mittel soll laut kommission an die
eu staaten entsprechend ihres
bevölkerungsanteils verteilt werden
anselm stern hat details das ist die
bislang grösste anti krisen hoffnung der
wirkstoff von beyond eck und pfizer noch
nicht zugelassen und schon schwer
begehrt europa meldet heute einen deal
sichert sich bis zu 300 millionen dosen
damit könnten etwa 150 millionen
europäer geimpft werden wo man mehrfach
impfen muss zum beispiel hepatitis
impfung muss mehrfach geimpft werden und
so ist es auch bei den corona
virusimpfstoffe nur bei den meisten
davon dass halt zu einem impfstoff im
schutz zwei impfungen benötigt werden
die deutsche regierung will impfstoff
für insgesamt 100 millionen antivirus
spritzen beschaffen wie viele es
tatsächlich werden noch nicht ganz
sicher
fest steht viele millionen dosen müssen
transportiert gelagert verteilt und
verabreicht werden
wir brauchen impfzentren wegen der
besonderen kühlketten die hier
organisiert werden müssen wir brauchen
im ärzte die also hier nochmal
herangezogen werden das werden
sicherlich auch zum teil pensionierte
erst zu sagen müssen das ist eine sehr
aufwendige logistik de bedient werden
muss aufwändig der impfstoff braucht
aktuell etwa minus 70 grad dabei soll
die bundeswehr helfen etwa gesicherte
lagerflächen zur verfügung stellen für
das mittel dass die krise irgendwann
einmal tatsächlich
könnte das ist eine jahrhundert
situation
es ist anstrengend ist es mühsam ist es
manchmal echt hart aber zu wissen es ist
nicht für immer kann ja nochmal
zusätzliche stärke und unterstützung für
diese zeit geben denn diese aktuelle
zeit der krise mit virus und ohne
impfstoff wird noch eine weile dauern
die eu hat kräftig gerungen um sich
diesen potenziellen impfstoff zu sichern
gunnar krüger in brüssel was war der
heikelste punkt die eu-kommission
verhandelt ja im namen aller 27
mitgliedsstaaten eben mit diesem
konsortium aus der deutschen bei und
theke und dem amerikanischen pharmamulti
pfizer und der grund weshalb die eu im
vergleich zu den usa bei so einem
verkaufsvertrag ein bisschen hinterher
hinkte der liegt einfach in einem
knackpunkt und das ist die haftungsfrage
die frage welche haftungsregeln welches
haftungs gesetz gilt im fall von einer
komplikation für die gibt es ja bis dann
keinen anlass anzunehmen aber für diesen
fall könnten daneben deutsche oder
europäische bürger dann auch vor
europäischen gerichten klagen die
eu-kommission hat darauf bestanden die
anwälte von pfizer wollten das
eigentlich nicht die eu hat sich jetzt
aber durchgesetzt und zum einen mit
verweis auf die vielen fördergelder die
sie in die diesen forschungserfolg
gesteckt hat und zum anderen natürlich
mit verweis auf ihre enorme marktmacht
was nochmal zeigt die eu handelt
vielleicht spät aber wenn sie dann
handelt dann geeint handelt dann
durchaus mit viel macht in formation
live aus brüssel von grün und gruga
vielen dank hierzulande ist die zahl der
korona neuinfektionen gesunken und liegt
aktuell etwa auf dem niveau der vorigen
woche das robert koch institut meldet 15
1332 neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden
die zahl der toten stieg um 154
mittlerweile gelten aber auch mehr als
400 41.000 menschen als genesen genießen
heißt allerdings nicht immer dass alles
wieder gut ist das hat auch der
bundespräsident heute erfahren
von betroffenen die ja zum gespräch
geladen hatte viele berichten von
langzeit folgen
patricia wiedemeier nadja als server
eine der ersten berliner corona
patientinnen anfang märz erkrankte sie
was sich anfühlte wie eine starke grippe
war
corona sie gilt längst als genesen doch
nach wie vor leidet die yogalehrerin
unter anderem an atemnot und müdigkeit
konzentrationsschwäche und auch
teilweise dass ich so nicht war aber so
ein bisschen ja nicht so ganz da bin
auch der arzt heinz wilhelm esser hatte
corona jedoch ohne symptome gemerkt hat
er später durch eine vaskulitis ist eine
gefäßentzündung an den beinen ja ich war
ein corona erkrankt und habe mir da eine
vaskulitis zugezogen und so wie es
aussieht eben ein post infektes aus marl
sowie den beiden ergeht es vielen über
genesene mit spätfolgen wird kaum
geredet der bundespräsident lud deshalb
fünf corona genesene 1
es ging um erfahrungen mit der krankheit
um konsequenzen
deutlich kritisierte steinmeier die
demonstrationen in leipzig wo einige
zehntausende menschen am wochenende die
krone auflagen missachtet
demonstrationen müssen möglich sein aber
demonstrationsfreiheit ist eben nicht
die freiheit zur gefährdung von anderen
denn es könne jeden treffen sowie
joachim huber er lag fünf wochen im koma
braucht mindestens ein jahr für seine
reha ich hatte nur noch vier prozent
jungen funktions tätigkeit dazu kam
sofort ein nierenversagen und zwar ein
komplettes und am ende aller tage
nachdem ich fast das überlebt hatte kam
ein herzinfarkt ich kann jeden zeigen
was der virus mit einem anrichten kann
und wenn du das pech hast dann kriegst
du auch noch alles drei menschen müssten
achtsamer werden mit sich selber und mit
anderen so die forderungen aller heute
corona hat viele facetten und folgen
auch menschen mit depressionen trifft es
besonders hart unter anderem weil viele
arzt termine abgesagt werden mehr zu
einer neuen studie in unserer zdf heute
app
frankreich war und ist von der korona
pandemie viel stärker betroffen als
deutschland inzwischen sind dort mehr
als 41.000 menschen am oder mit dem
virus gestorben
seit einer woche gelten zum zweiten mal
in diesem jahr weitreichende
beschränkungen des öffentlichen lebens
die schulen sind wie bei uns weiter
geöffnet das bereitet manchen aber große
sorgen christel hass an dieser schule
wird gestreikt genauso wie an vielen
anderen auch protestiert wird nicht
gegen dem neuen lockdown sondern für
merkur ohne schutz im klassenzimmer
denn der unterricht geht weiter wir
wollen hier arbeiten sagt die lehrerin
aber so nicht wir müssten die klassen
teilen es gibt zu wenig platz nicht nur
lehrer und schüler sind in sorge
das ganze land blickt auf die
krankenhäuser immer mehr corona fälle
die intensivstationen sind wieder am
limit
wieder müssen patienten verlegt werden
auch wieder nach deutschland
heute morgen wurde dieser mann per
hubschrauber nach dortmund gebracht
uns fehlen betten durch die verlegungen
können wir andere erkrankte aufnehmen
das bett dieses patienten wird in
wenigen stunden wieder belegt sein
entlastung mehr betten verspricht dieses
mobile krankenhaus das sich wie eine
ziehharmonika entfaltet und 18 patienten
aufnehmen kann
es ist seit kurzem im süden im einsatz
ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
glück bikini der peak der epidemie steht
noch vor uns die zweite welle steigt
weiter an
wir müssen uns noch mehr anstrengen und
sie noch stärker bremsen
in den krankenhäusern wird also der
druck noch steigen und die zahl der
toten wohl auch und so bleibt oft nur
die hoffnung dass anderswo noch betten
frei sind um leben zu retten
lange hat das eben parlament mit den
mitgliedstaaten über die künftigen
finanzen der union gestritten jetzt
haben sich die unterhändler auf einen
kompromiss verständigt
danach soll mehr geld in forschung
bildung und gesundheit fließen
beschlossen ist der haushalt aber noch
nicht alle staaten und das parlament
müssen noch abschließend zustimmen
erst dann kann auch das vereinbarte
corona hilfsprogramm über 750 milliarden
euro starten in die usa
dort weigert sich präsident tom nach wie
vor seine niederlage einzugestehen er
will weiterhin das wahlergebnis also den
sieg von joe biden vor gericht anfechten
und nutzt dafür auch seinen
justizminister aus washington
ines trams der terminplan von präsident
trump ist leer blicken lässt er sich
nicht seine niederlage erkennt er
bislang nicht an
es scheint als wolle er das weiße haus
nicht als verlierer verlassen sondern
als der der wegen wahlbetrugs gehen muss
ich werde gewinnen twitter der und
stimmzettel missbrauch während seine
anwälte die klagen gegen die
stimmauszählung vorantreiben schickt er
verbündete wie seine sprecherin auf
pr-tour als sie von wahlbetrug der
demokraten spricht unterbricht trans
lieblings sender fox news die
übertragung solange sie nicht beweise
liefert kann ich ihnen das nicht weiter
mit gutem gewissen zeigen unterstützung
hingegen kommt von kramp justizminister
keine klage des teams hatte bislang
erfolg doch er gibt den staatsanwälten
der regierung die erlaubnis
substanzielle vorwürfe zu untersuchen
trump feuer derweil seinen
verteidigungsminister
mit ihm hatte er sich überworfen nun so
scheint es folgt die rache riskant
einer ehe unruhigen übergangsphase von
einer regierung zur nächsten
im pentagon sorgt man sich um die
nationale sicherheit
wie sieht das in peking aus wie in
moskau teheran caracas oder pjöngjang
klasse sieht das für die aus sie lieben
es was hier passiert überall klatschen
sie sich an eine woche nach dem wahltag
ist klar
joe biden hat einen herausfordernden weg
ins weiße haus vor sich nach sechs
wochen krieg gibt es im kaukasus
konflikt um berg-karabach eine
entscheidende wende armenien und
aserbaidschan vereinbarten unter
russischer vermittlung ein ende der
kämpfe
daraufhin gab es in armeniens hauptstadt
jerewan in der nacht gewaltsame proteste
gegen das abkommen
armenien verliert in bergkarabach weite
teile des von ihm bisher kontrollierten
gebiets an aserbaidschan
der rest wird weiterhin von armenien
verwaltet aber von knapp 2.000
russischen soldaten bewacht
was können wir gemeinsam tun gegen
islamistischen terror darüber berät
heute die bundeskanzlerin mit ihren
kollegen aus frankreich und österreich
anlass waren die jüngsten anschläge
radikalisierter muslime anfang oktober
tötet in dresden ein als gefährlich
eingestufter syrer einen mann mitte
oktober enthauptet ein 18 jähriger in
paris eine lehrer in nizza werden drei
menschen in einer kirche ermordet und
vor gut einer woche wien ots anhänger
erschießt viel menschen über die antwort
der regierungschefs andrea maurer
der islamistische terror ist zurück in
europa und mit ihm angst wut trauer und
die fragen nach politischen konsequenzen
in einer video konferenz hat kanzlerin
merkel heute mit österreichs kanzler
kurz frankreichs präsident makro dem
niederländischen ministerpräsidenten
rote und der eu spitze über eine
gemeinsame europäische strategie beraten
es geht darum dass das demokratische
gesellschaftsmodell sich mit
terroristischen und antidemokratischen
verhalten auseinandersetzen muss und
dies mit grosser aufrichtigkeit und
entschiedener stärke schon vor der
konferenz hatten sich makro und kurz im
élyseepalast getroffen die beiden
regierungschefs haben in ihren ländern
acht terroropfer innerhalb von einem
monat zu beklagen
beide gaben heute den ton vor politische
härte tausende dschihadisten seien in
europa außengrenzen müssten besser
geschützt werden
das sind tickende zeitbomben
und wenn wir unser aller freiheit
schützen wollen dann müssen wir die
freiheit dieser menschen einschränken es
braucht meiner meinung nach ein robustes
vorgehen gegenüber den gefährdern in
ganz europa das versprechen von der
freizügigkeit ohne binnengrenzen basiert
auf dem versprechen dass unsere
außengrenzen sicher sind wir können
jetzt die grenzen nicht weiter offen
halten ohne den schengen raum
grundsätzlich zu reformieren
konkret wurden mehr kontrollen an den
schengen aussengrenzen genannt und mehr
schleierfahndung an innereuropäischen
grenzen
die konferenz heute soll ein signal der
entschlossenheit sein
am freitag wollen die eu-innenminister
über maßnahmen beraten
eine wichtige rolle im kampf gegen den
extremismus spielen die moscheegemeinden
und deren imame was sie lehren wie sie
den islam interpretieren kann vor allem
für junge gläubige den ausschlag geben
ein problem
die meisten imame kommen aus dem ausland
vor allem aus der türkei kennen sich oft
in der gesellschaft hierzulande nicht
aus ein ausweg ausbildung in deutschland
thema der islam konferenz heute in
osnabrück beginnt bald ein unabhängiges
projekt mit 30 künftigen imamen
gefördert vom deutschen staat elisabeth
schmidt imame ausgebildet in deutschland
darauf haben die leiter des neuen islam
kollegs in osnabrück fast zehn jahre
lang hingearbeitet
und sie versprechen maximale transparenz
die lehrpläne werden veröffentlicht und
die unterrichtssprache ist
ausschließlich deutsch
wir haben rund 2500 moscheegemeinden in
deutschland die allermeisten davon
sprechen gar nicht oder schlecht deutsch
gleichzeitig wird ein pädagogisches
verständnis in diesen gemeinden an den
tag gelegt dass mit unserer
lebenswirklichkeit nichts zu tun hat und
hier müssen wir gegensteuern weg vom
einfluss radikaler hassprediger darum
geht es auch dem bundesinnenministerium
welches das islam kolleg maßgeblich
finanziert gerade vor dem hintergrund
der rahmenbedingungen die es ja auch
gibt in europa insgesamt mit diesen
schrecklichen anschlägen von fanatischen
islamisten
denn eine deutsche imame ausbildung ist
auch ein beitrag zur prävention
doch diese ziele sind in ihrer umsetzung
fraglich machen doch die großen moschee
verbände beim islam kolleg nicht mit sie
pochen auf ihre ausbildungs hort des
projektes lang kolleg ist ein
modellversuch ist es noch nicht erprobt
und die debatte was das betrifft seit
jahren erfahrungen sie hat die
kenntnisse und das ist die eigene
verantwortung deshalb machen wir nicht
mit
die meisten imame kommen aus der türkei
diese zahl müsse begrenzt werden fordert
heute der bundesinnenminister
er setzt stattdessen auf das islam
kolleg in osnabrück und auf
deutschsprachige imame körperverletzung
vergewaltigung oder auch totschlag viele
gewalttaten passieren zu hause in
partnerschaften
laut der von familienministerin giffey
vorgestellten bka statistik wurden
vergangenes jahr fast 142.000 delikte
gemeldet 0,7 prozent mehr als im jahr
davor
81 prozent der frauen der opfer waren
frauen die dunkelziffer sagen experten
ist hoch hunderte vorwiegend junge leute
hatten im juni in der stuttgarter
innenstadt randaliert polizisten
angegriffen und geschäfte geplündert
heute gab es die ersten urteile und die
vielen härter aus als staatsanwaltschaft
und verteidigung gefordert hatten
zwei randalierer wurden wegen besonders
schweren landfriedensbruch zu einer
jugendstrafe von zweieinhalb jahren haft
verurteilt die randale hatten bundesweit
eine hitzige debatte über sicherheit und
gewalt
ausgelöst jetzt mit dem sport morgen
tritt die fußball-nationalmannschaft an
freundschaftsspiel gegen tschechien und
das ist ein besonderes gutes pflaster
für bundestrainer joachim löw der hat
nämlich dort alle länder spiele gewonnen
ein wichtiger test vor allem für von den
beiden letzten nations league
gruppenspielen gegen die ukraine und
spanien
und wie heißt es doch so schön ein sieg
würde der mannschaft gut tun ist das
schon ein ärmel hochkrempeln oder ist
die jacke nur ein bisschen groß sicher
ist die nationalmannschaft muss auch
morgen verlorene sympathien zurück
erkämpfen
dass viele fans auch sich momentan noch
schwer tun sich auf länderspiele zu
freuen das gefühl habe ich auch ehrlich
gesagt vielleicht hat es auch damit zu
tun dass beliebte ehemalige
leistungsträger aus ihrem wm formtief
inzwischen längst empor gestiegen sind
im moment gibt es keine rückkehr von
thomas müller von mats hummels von
jerome boateng
sollte sich die situation vor der em
völlig anders darstellen
schlüsselpositionen falle aus wegen
großer probleme bewerte die situation
völlig neu
morgen wird deshalb neben torhüter trapp
der eine oder andere debütant zum zuge
kommen um die zukunft des deutschen
profifußballs geht es morgen bei einem
treffen von 14 erstligisten und des hsv
in frankfurt am main
anlass die finanziellen sorgen der klubs
durch die pandemie thema aber auch die
künftige verteilung der tv gelder
klammheimlich hat bayern vorstand karl
heinz rummenigge das treffen eingefädelt
die 18 erstligavereine sollten nicht
alle dabei sein
in mainz moniert man es sei ein
merkwürdiges verhalten wenn teile der
liga ausgeschlossen würden nicht
eingeladen sind augsburg bielefeld mainz
und stuttgart die vier hatten zuletzt
die neue verteilung der tv gelder
zugunsten kleinerer vereine
vorgeschlagen demnach soll der tabellen
erste nur noch höchstens doppelt so viel
geld erhalten wie der tabellenletzte
bisher bekommt der erste rund das
vierfache
weniger geld für top klubs also in
leverkusen unterstützt man die
rummenigge initiative und spricht von
einem richtungsweisenden treffen morgen
in frankfurt
das war von mir wir haben jetzt noch
eine corona idee aus rom für
modebewusste herren elegante unterwegs
aber maske vergessen kein drama einfach
den schlips ausklappen den filmstoff
übers gesicht fertig ist die korona
krawatte
die soll sogar antibakteriell sein
schutz uns die zugleich doch das wetter
ist nicht ganz super fed nebel ein
bisschen sonne und ein bisschen regen
die details hat vielleicht katja hornuf
christian sievers begrüßt sie um
fünfzehnten heute journal
wir sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend machen müssen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren so viele
tropische wirbelstürme über dem atlantik
gab es noch nie das hier ist der 29
tropische wirbelsturm täter er zieht
weiter nach osten und wird
wahrscheinlich am wochenende oder anfang
nächster woche madeira erreichen
mit unserem wetter hier in mitteleuropa
hat er wenig zu tun das wird dominiert
durch nebel hier zum beispiel im harz da
sahen sie die sonne von anbeginn an aber
sie sehen auch häufig gibt es neblig
trüb und jetzt in der nacht bildet sich
gleich wieder neuer nebel
westlich des rheins kann es auch ein
bisschen nieselregen geben geringe
sichtweiten es kann auch mal glatt seien
auf den strassen jedenfalls im osten da
sinken die werte auf 3 bis 0 grad milder
bleibt die nacht im westen bei 10 bis 6
grad und die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 6 grad an der donau und
16 grad am niederrhein und das wird für
viele wieder ein trüber tag mit nebel
mit hochnebel selten mal mit etwas
sonnenschein zb nordosten oder auch in
nordrhein westfalen zum beispiel im
schwarzwald oder auch an den alpen in
den nächsten tag kommt aber bewegung ins
wetter denn es wird windiger damit kommt
etwas regen heran und dann geht es den
nebel mehr und mehr an den kragen
schönen abend noch